to attack the default Pawn E3 and now G5  this variation has been around for a few  years now I remember  this was first time I saw this was uh  nihal with the white side against uh  Swani and  um  Bishop G3 H5 these variations these  questions get quite wild for both the  sides it's not the threat of a bishop  trapped immediately because the bishop  does have the first Square so white can  continue with Bishop B5 white can  continue with Knight F3 here or just  stop the H Pawn with H4 but it's more to  do with I think the control of the  center the Knight coming to E4 and  the control of the center rather than  something immediate against white skin  or the bishop  very interesting Dynamics here and of  course  has gone into a bit of  a sink here